(audience applauds)
- All righty then.
Welcome, it is time for Drew's News.
We cast out our line
(mimics reel whooshing)
and we reel in that good old news tuna.
- Ah-ha?
- Catch a keeper.
And with me at the desk
is my chicken of the sea,
Ross Matthews.
- You caught a big one.
(audience applauds)
Hi, hi!
(upbeat music)
- First up I found this
story to be a total delight.
Our favorite girl, Dakota Johnson.
That's right.
Her and I do the Little Yellow Book
and her company, TeaTime,
we curate lists together.
So she's a dear friend of our show
and she just revealed one
of her favorite hobbies.
People reports that Dakota
says in her spare time
she loves to crash weddings.
- [Ross] What?
(audience gasps)
- How fun is that?
I just rewatched "Wedding
Crashers" this weekend too.
So I was primed for this.
One time, she said she was holding up
a bride and groom in a chair.
I mean, what, Hava nagila? I love it.
And they looked down and they were like,
"Oh, whoa, what are you doing here?
(audience laughs)
Dakota? You little minx,
I love this about you.
All your layers.
Come crash our show or
our wedding anytime soon.
(audience applauds)
Have you ever crashed anything, Rossy?
- I would never crash
a wedding in my life.
Especially since I'm planning one now.
All I'm thinking to myself is
like, "That's three shrimp.
That's three shrimp!"
Right? We plan ahead.
- This is what's happening on TikTok.
It's exactly what you think it is.
Apparently you boil potato
chips out of the bag
and then mash 'em into a paste.
And then you add in milk, butter or cream
and salt and pepper to taste.
I think it sounds like
a goblin moment, right?
- Oh definitely.
- Yeah.
- Okay. So...
Sorry, I'm salivating.
- Uh-huh.
- So this is, remember like, Idaho Spuds
and Potato Buds?
- Oh my God, the boxed potato.
I didn't know mashed potatoes
came from an actual potato
until I was like 20.
I thought it just was out of the box.
- [Drew] So this, it feels like kind of a,
I don't know some version of that.
- Yeah.
- Is that it?
- I want it to be really good, right?
- Well, one, two, three.
- Okay.
- Okay. Ready?
- Thank you.
- Hm.
- Yeah.
- Y'all don't like it.
(audience laughs)
- No, we love it.
- Oh. (laughs)
- We get mad when we like it,
because then it's like, "Oh
no, now it's gonna be a thing".
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- Oh, this sucks.
(audience laughs)
- Now this is gonna haunt my dream.
- Do you all practice
the five second rule?
Raise of hands, who does
- [Ross] Be honest, yeah.
- [Drew] I mean, I've done
like the 10 second rule.
- [Ross] Right?
- Okay, marthastewart.com reports
that scientists have actually tested
the five second rule in a lab.
They dropped a piece of baloney.
Well, that's just like...
- That's gross already.
- That's like tape.
- Yeah, right?
- Of course it's gonna pick something up.
- (laughs) It's totally tape!
- And a piece of dry
bread on a surface with,
ugh, salmonella on it.
- Hmm?
- And they let it sit for
five seconds, 30 seconds
and then a full minute
and the results are in.
Regardless of how long it's sat there,
the food was very definitely contaminated.
- [Ross] Oh man. (groans)
- Even after just five seconds
that baloney was salmonella city.
- [Ross] I know.
- [Both] Oh God.
- Well, I mean, oh man.
- I feel like there are two types
of five second rules in the world.
There's like five second
rule around people.
And you're like, "No,
I'm not gonna, mm-mm."
And then there's the
five second rule at home,
where you're like that's
been there for like,
I don't know, a few minutes.
I actually, one time
just found a jellybean
(audience laughs)
And I ate it.
- This story really spoke to me.
The Baltimore Museum of Art
just opened a new exhibit
curated by their own security guards.
The Week, my favorite magazine,
reports the exhibit is
called "Guarding the Art"
and it's up through July.
So the museum asked 17
of their security guards
that obviously, are in the,
you know, building all day, every day,
to select works from the collection
that were important and
meaningful to the security guards.
Guard Ben Bjork picked a
chair made out of pencils
by artist Jeremy Aldean,
because Ben says he spends
a lot lot of the day
thinking about sitting down.
(audience laughs)
- Well yeah, right?
- Um, Ross?
- The fact that they got
to choose to curate a show
based on what they love,
just made me feel like it was
so accessible and so doable.
I felt no, that's a show I wanna go see.
So well done to this museum.
(bright music)